wenn personen wie er so etwas riskantes
tun dann ist es oft gar nicht so geplant
wie viele denken häufig sind sie
vermindert schuldfähig oder sogar
schuldunfähig was aber selten vorkommt
indem sie beispielsweise unter alkohol
oder drogeneinfluss stehen oder eine
psychische störung vorliegt oder eben
eine ganz extrem verminderte intelligenz
jetzt muss man aber vorsichtig sein ja
er hat eine verminderte intelligenz und
ja auch eine schwere seelische
abartigkeit wurde festgestellt aber das
heißt nicht zwangsläufig dass jemand
schuldunfähig ist personen können
durchaus eine psychische störung haben
oder intelligenz eine
intelligenzminderung haben und trotzdem
sehr klar das unrechte tat erkennen und
die tatsache dass er sie noch getäuscht
hat dass er mit einem trick er will ja
was zeigen und ihr stiefbruder und die
eltern wissen bescheid er hat ja hier
täuschung an gewänder um sie zu
überlisten
auch die tatsache dass er schon vorher
auffällig war dass er bereits
kinderpornografisches material auf
seinen geräten hatte spricht dafür dass
er schon sehr genau wusste was er getan
hat aber das muss das gericht jetzt
klären inwiefern die schuldfähigkeit im
raum steht ja gott sei dank die
höchststrafe lebenslang mit sicherheits
und neben dieser hohen strafe die ihn
hoffentlich erwartet würde auch auf zu
klären sein was im vorfeld passierte
warum dieser mann eben vorher nicht in
einer therapie gelandet ist und wer das
zu verantworten
dank für das gespräch in dem profiler
markt hoffmann wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren